-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy Award-winning actress
and comedian
you know from her work
in "Girls Trip"
and "The Last O.G."
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Tiffany Haddish.
Tiffany, I am always so happy
to see you.
You are such a positive person.
I believe you to be an
optimistic person.
You're a very funny person.
It must be so difficult
for you to find the way
to talk about this moment
that we're living through.
-It's extremely difficult.
You know, Seth,
I like to think of myself
as an administrator of joys --
someone who
when I come into a scene,
any worries or woes
that you might have
can be alleviated or removed.
But during this time,
it has been so difficult
for me to express
any kind of joy
or bring any kind of happiness
or anything 'cause it's --
'cause I'm watching --
I'm literally sitting back,
watching the world fall apart --
what it feels like.
And it feels like
it needs to fall apart.
Things need to fall apart
and be put back together again
in a way that's fair.
-You, uh -- You were at George
Floyd's funeral in Minneapolis,
and what was it like
being there?
What made you decide to go?
Were you happy, in the end,
that you went?
-I -- Okay, so, I decided to go
because I was invited.
Right?
I was invited to be there.
Um...and the main thing that
made me want to be there --
Mind you, I ain't been nowhere,
okay?
[ Chuckles ] In months.
But the thing that made me
really want to be there
is I have watched my friends
be slaughtered by the police.
I have watched people be
murdered in front of me
as a 13-year-old, 14-year-old
girl, you know?
And there was nothing I can do
except "No! Don't do that!"
Yelling out?
What did that do? Like...
And so I wanted to be there
in support of the family
because I understand
how they feel,
and being there was like...
being there for all my friends
whose funerals
I already went to.
But all my friends
who passed away,
all the people that I went to
school with who've passed away,
have been locked up
for no reason,
just 'cause they can't afford
a good lawyer
or, you know, accused of things
that they didn't do.
And being there was so powerful,
'cause I did not know
it was gonna be televised.
I had no idea that it
was gonna be televised.
I thought there would be cameras
outside or whatever.
But that was my first time
walking into a funeral
that was televised and a funeral
of someone who was being --
who was killed
by a police officer.
You know?
And I thought that
was really tremendous.
And I -- I remember I was like,
"Kevin, put your mask on.
Y'all need to put your mask on."
Nobody wanted
to put their mask on.
I don't know why.
But I'm "Put your mask on
if you're sitting next to me."
They didn't want to put it on.
But Will Packer put his on.
And, you know, the serv--
the eulogies that were given
were so powerful.
It was a great message.
And I cried so much.
I cried so much.
I was crying so much,
and it was like tears of
not just for Floyd but for --
for all of those people
that passed away and all of my
friends and my family members
that are locked up
and, like, it was just like
all the tears that
I ever wanted to cry
were coming up,
and I was trying to swallow
them, trying to swallow them.
When they had that moment
of silence --
that 8 minutes and 46 seconds
of silence on that stage...
And I'm standing there next to
one of the mothers of a victim,
and I'm -- the quietness
and then the thought of
what if someone's knee
was in my neck for this long?
[ Voice breaking ]
How helpless were my friends
when they were being attacked,
you know?
I just couldn't -- the tears --
I was trying to swallow them
and they was coming out
through my nose
and my mask was full of snot.
And I was, like, holding it,
trying to, like,
keep the snot off my mouth.
But ain't no holding it.
And I wasn't gonna take it off
'cause I didn't want to look
like a scene out of a bad movie.
And I just --
The pain --
The amount of pain that I felt
was tremendous.
And -- And as we're leaving out
of there and I --
You know, people are like,
"Oh, they already Tweeting
about you.
They already Tweeting
about you."
And I'm like,
"I didn't do anything!"
I didn't do anything and already
being, like, attacked.
And I'm like, "It's not about --
I don't care if they're Tweeting
about me."
If they're Tweeting about me
and that's bringing
more attention
to what's going on right now,
great.
But when I took that mask off
and all that snot
was all over in here,
that was not okay.
But the next day, my skin
was so soft all from here,
so I found out
about snot facials.
-There you go.
So, uh...
there's at least one
very tiny, tiny positive.